oh well
i'm alive that's the first thing i
noticed about myself this morning when i
got up
i'm still alive
you know it's uh
it's not a guarantee some people dying
or sleep i wonder how if i would like
that
dying in my sleep uh
i almost the thing about dying and
you're sleeping people don't think about
this
if you die in your sleep you don't get
any last words you don't get
that last uh
serving of outspoken you don't get to
say anything
if you're stabbed or if you you know
fall down some stairs or you know if
you're stabbed you can
oh you know what why you stabbing me
wha what do you stub me
you know and then maybe some famous
quote or something you get to do you
know
uh i could have been a contender give me
liberty give me death you know
uh from the window to the wall
you know
i mean you get to at least if you are
a li if you're out and about or if
you're
if you're not asleep if you're not dying
in your sleep you get that last moment
you know even if you're falling down
some stairs you're like
oh dang this is the last time i
gonna be five
what the [ __ ]
you but at least you get to you get a
final say
because otherwise if you just die in
your sleep you just get that epithet
and epithat is something people write it
on your uh
on that gravestone that death marker
you know that uh
that funeral yard
um
little placard or placard i'm not sure i
think it is french origin
but then then somebody else guesses you
know what they would you would have said
you know or they'd give you a final
little hoo-ha
on there so
what do you think you'd do raleigh mal
would you die in your sleep or would you
you want to go out in a living moment
i think i want to go out in a living
moment
and what would you have a final word or
something would you get a
when you get one final jab in at the
world of verbal
jab uh
yeah i don't know i would say uh you
know
something all righty we'll come back to
you bud
we'll come back to you with that today's
episode is brought to you by
grey block pizza
1811 pico boulevard on the way to the
beach in los angeles
great block get that hitter baby let's
get into it
come on baby this is
89 volt the come up
i'm
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well i just got home and now i'm back
[Music]
and that's that right there baby that'll
get you
and if that don't get you then you
probably can't be god
if that don't get you you probably can't
be got
because music has that infectious
ability you know there's um
[Music]
there's there's very few things that can
just
get you immediately
out of nowhere and make you behave
differently a dog bite
can do it a bee
a bumblebee baby they can do it really
heavily
if they choose if they wanna if they're
feeling like it
a dog bite a bee
what else um
lightning which is really just
god's bumble bee baby
and
music those are the things that can
really get you
just take you from nothing to something
and an escalator
those are about the five things that can
really maybe shift what's going on with
you
i went to the fights that's what i did
this past weekend i went out there to
las vegas
and uh man it was
it was a scorcher
the plane couldn't even land because at
first uh
the runway was 115 degree
and they said that if the runway if it's
higher than 114 or something they can't
land
so that took an extra 40 minutes
of delay time and then you're
sitting there and it's uh
you know it just then you're having to
kind of mingle and p
there was two like just thoughts i mean
i
i mean just real
girls that it looked like they'd just
been the kind of girls that'll just
they've they'll just look like they've
been beaten up at even at christmas
and they just one of them were just so
aggravating and just kept ordering
drinks and the guy the guy in the
uh you know the server or the
flight attendant sorry i mean server
but the flight attendant the air man he
said we can't have drain
the lady cat like ordered three times
and
just a nightmare and i just
wish that i was italian enough to
do that thing or when you're sitting
behind somebody in
a in an italian movie sometimes the
person in the backseat will put a cord
around the person in the front seats
neck
and just lace them up like a shoe until
they're not alive anymore
and uh that's what i wanted to do
i wanted to do that there was two girls
one of them
deserved to live i'ma say it i'll put it
like that the other one
we didn't need her
we didn't need her did we need her
nope we sure didn't
she said i don't know jesus christ
and who's emailing me now best buy bunch
of [ __ ] what do they think i'm gonna
do
hey best buy let me say this to you
okay every night you want to email me
around midnight 1am
first of all your stores aren't even
open at that time
have you thought about that second of
all what do you think i'm gonna do
you think i'ma get out of bed
with my stuffed animal or with a girl
maybe
but you think i'm gonna get out of bed
to go look at one of your xeroxers or
look at one of your 71 inchers
it's 1am
and you guys are beating me over the
damn screen face
with your you know we got toasters we
got mortal
you know mortal warrior 60.
you know join the club join the group
don't you want this oven [ __ ] i'm
asleep
i don't need an oven while i'm sleeping
all right i'm trying to get some rest
i'm not trying to get a deal
best buy
so you best believe me
when i tell you to limit the [ __ ] alone
in emails
but um anyway yeah so i got out to the
fights
and uh and what was going on
i mean there was first of all it was a
packed event
you know i get over there um
and well did you watch the fights
raleigh mao did you watch the fights
brother
i did not all righty what'd you do over
the weekend bub
uh film the wedding oh wow
and whose was it don't know it was a
catholic wedding
oh okay and now what's the times
like what's the time commitment you're
gonna go film a wedding what kind of
time commitment is that
pretty much all day okay and do you have
a certain
shot list you like to try to get i do
okay and is there any kind of sneaky
shots will you get something like uh
is there any stuff you try to sneak in
the back room or hide behind a window or
something get some
a little perverse not perverse but you
know what i'm saying something that's
gonna
you know make them cover the baby's eyes
if if they're watching the video back
it's gonna make them cover the child's
eyes if they're in there watching it
i do not okay so you guys really more of
a pg
outfit over there yeah yeah pretty much
okay
and have you ever filmed a wedding where
you didn't think that they should go
through with it
not that i could think of already
is it how's your own love life going man
last time we'd had you here
here you had a real there was a a woman
who'd let you down
from memphis i remember yeah kendra i
think was her name
what was it i
i don't even remember it was i got her
out of my mind
wow yeah isn't it funny how it'll happen
how one day it's the most important
thing to you and then
and then it's uh old mail
you know exactly um
what's up with your wedding bells on
your own front is there any new
relationships in your life
uh unfortunately not okay okay still
looking
you still looking huh yeah are you on
the app so you just letting the
you just living right you letting the
lord work what's how
how you managing it uh i'm i'm just
letting the lord work hey man bubby
hey man um
and what about are you do you you know i
struggle over the years with a little
bit of pornography do you struggle with
it or you're good
i don't i'm good god you're lucky dear
god
[ __ ] um
all right well i'll tell you about the
fights man
okay you guys if you didn't see the
fight i mean it was uh first of all i
get there there's tons of
um you know joe rogan has done an
amazing job over the years he created
this unique
bridge where um where
comedy and where comedians and fighters
are
are
allowed to co-mingle and and there's a
mutual kind of i don't know if it's a
it's definitely a respect
in the fighters direction but there's a
like i got to go up to max holloway and
say hello
you know and he knew who i was
i mean that was like made my life
you know um you know
you're able to in my dms i'm
communicating with other fighters i run
into other fighters
and there's just like uh ricky simone um
[Music]
you know uh corey sandhagen and i will
communicate
some like uh tai tui vasa who was
drinking beer out the boot up there on
that cage
after he gave greg hardly that i mean he
hit i mean he just hit him
he gave him that fat rattler baby you
know he [ __ ] hit him with that new
zealand brown snake baby you feel me
he really shook him down with that
freaking
that big coconut cane pole daddy he ty
really
he snuck him he snuck him with that
magic arm duck
you know he bit him with that freaking
he bit him with that big that elbow
quacker dog you know
that dirty duck that left or that right
i don't remember which one it was but
um but there's just a way like
and that's all because of joe rogan you
know joe rogan did
does comedy he's done he does ufc he's
the voice of ufc and so
you're just it's interesting he's
allowed to use it allowed to co-mingle
with those people
and there's a level of i don't know if
it's it's definitely respect with the
towards the fighters because you know
they're fighters so you
there's always a lot of respect towards
fighters um
but there's a there's a level of respect
that comes back from those guys towards
the comedians and stuff
you know i think it's interesting
because
you know we all put ourselves out there
in some way
to get an energy or a vibe or something
to get a to be seen or heard
you know fighters they're fighting to
get that
you know they want to be we're all
trying to prove something
we're all trying to fill in a a void
or a necessity
there's these spaces inside of us that
are missing a building block
and we're all trying to
out in the world just chiseling
different moments and different
goals to get them to feel
whatever that space is
and um and i noticed a lot i noticed
between fighters i noticed that between
comedians i know
between strippers uh pornograph
pornographists
um but yeah this need
to to be seen or noticed uh
or complete
um but yeah and
joe rogans really build that br he but
he he makes it okay
kind of for comedians and fighters to
interact because he's that lego
that's keeping that uh both of those
entities connected
um yeah i went to the fight uh
i didn't know that joe rogan had left me
two tickets
so i get there i got one t i i just
brought myself
you know um
so i get there i got suddenly i got two
tickets but it's already into the
uh undercard so i texted a couple people
i didn't know anyone that lived in vegas
so i texted glenn big baby davis he was
a guest
on this past weekend you know uh he was
he's a louisiana guy i figured i'm there
to see dustin
another louisiana guy to be great glenn
was i had just left town
and so then i'm stuck you know and i
thought about trying to text a hooker or
something but then
what if they show up they don't look
like their picture
and then now you're sitting next to some
lady that looks like bird and ernie
i don't know if you've ever done that
but some you get an escort they show up
they'll look like bert and ernie you're
like
dang okay this double puppet out here i
can't even
and nothing like the the picture they
had on the internet
that is a gone that is a i mean they
must have been hit by lightning
and stung by bees or something because
there will be a total different vibe or
energy
coming off that woman beautiful ladies
and i look and they're beautiful ladies
i'm just saying
the last minute
you also you don't want to get a
last-minute hooker that's not
some things there's or escort i
shouldn't say hooker like it's
you know it sounds a little i guess like
they're not doing anything
i mean hooker and but i respect hookers
and escorts i respect
anybody that's doing something like that
um
you ever consider anything like that
raleigh mao you ever considered in
you know uh
using you know some men or something if
they
if they're not having luck of women will
get out there and get a
lady of the night kind of
has it ever crossed your mind or what
i know a few people that have um but not
for me
okay and what do you think about like do
you feel do you look down on it or is
this not your thing
do you feel like it would be too nervous
of an interaction
uh it's just it's just not my thing yeah
and where what type of place are you
trying to meet ladies these days you had
little
laundromat or you doing are you
indoors outdoors where are you trying to
meet these gals
anywhere anywhere um never thought about
a laundromat
but hey can't go wrong
well i'll tell you what's good about a
laundromat is that
it's a place where uh women prefer to do
laundry
and i'm not saying it's a sexist thing
or a
you know i just and i'll be honest they
do it better
you know i've seen a dude with some
laundry and it's
it looks like somebody just kidnapped a
bunch of clothes
you know when you see a guy with some
laundry it looks like it shouldn't
really it looks sad
i'm gonna say that
but a woman you see the longer you see
her she's able it's just women are more
delicate
clothes are delicate so when you see the
two together
it just has a more
comfortable fit i'm not saying women
need to do laundry
i'm not saying that at all okay
i know a couple cushy viets you know a
couple of soft-handed viets you won't
even see them
touch the pillowcase and next thing you
know it's all you know folded into a
damn duck or into a damn uh
raven simone even one of them could even
fold it into a damn
you know a larry bird i mean you know
the ability sometimes of these
the small paws on a vietnamese person to
maneuver the cloth
into perfect shapes and stuff is uh
magnifique as they say abroad
uh magnifique
but um were we talking about
what are we talking about raleigh now
you remember
um can at the moment
alrighty man me neither bub so i'm gonna
let you off the hook on that one but uh
damn well anyway i went to the fights
dustin won i almost got to go in the
ring when he won which was which was
which would have been pretty cool i mean
it's
you know you're just there to support
him uh
you know it was also awesome to see sean
o'malley
um you know he's just an entertaining
guy
uh and you know he's trying to
you know add to his knockout resume
chris moutinho was the guy who fought
him
and the guy that was
one of the most exciting parts of the
night was when that guy took
just kept taking the hits from um
from sean o'malley because we all want
to like
keep going we all want to take the hits
and keep going
and we do we do it on a day-to-day basis
so to see this this little
i mean he had the green hair color this
little uh jolly rancher
he looked like a my little pony kind of
hopped up on jolly rancher candies
but to see him and i don't even say that
in a rude way i lo
you know i was fascinated it was it was
the it was one of the highlights of the
evening
people were chanting rocky at one point
um
to see him just keep going to see them
call the fight at the end
and not let him finish was a little
rough but uh
but man that was amazing
because we all want to take the hits and
keep going and he did that
uh yeah that was amazing man
um what else
what else is happening what else
happened this weekend we had some videos
that came in some submissions of things
that were going on
and i'll get into those in just a second
uh
we'll find out a little bit more what's
going on from uh mr riley mao and
and see what's happening out there in
the
on the uh on the in the hot
in the hot uh hot world and the
low-key christian
you know young fellow asian world we'll
get into that in just a second
i'm gonna tell you this wouldn't it be
great if there were a pocket-sized
guide that could help you sleep focus
act and be better well there is if you
have 10 minutes headspace can change
your life
headspace is one of the only meditation
apps advancing the field of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated research
so whatever the situation headspace
really can help you feel better
if you're overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation for you
god i need that you need help falling
asleep headspace has wind down
sessions i've used headspace
i like it it helps it's available
and it has the different options that's
the thing
it's backed by 25 published studies
six hundred thousand five star reviews
but look meditation is what you make it
you have to want it if you want it
you'll get it
you deserve to feel happier headspace is
meditation made simple go to
headspace.com
theo that's right go to headspace.com
t-h-e-o for a free one-month trial with
access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every situation
it's the best deal offered right now
head to headspace.com
theo today for a free one month trial
you deserve it i think i also want to
let you know that tickets are going on
sale
friday for uh the
netflix special taping we will be taping
in nashville
at the ryman auditorium you'll be able
to get those through theovonne.com
tour and that's where i would suggest
that you get them
um man it's gonna be exciting
uh what else oh i'll tell you this you
need to know it
that ship station is the one who can do
it for you
you know people sell things online you
ever sold something online riley now
i have what'd you sell bubbe
oh man i've sold ipads phones
a lot of stuff okay electronics
yup you can sell all types of things you
can also sell your crafts online you
ever done a craft rally
i have well you can sell them online
that's right
you can sell your crafts online at ship
station
yep that's it you can import orders from
any sales channel shipped with any
carrier
using ship stations deeply discounted
rates
automate just about any shipping task
no matter if you're selling through
shopify etsy
or your own website ship station
heck you could even sell ships if you
made small ships you could sell them hey
you're shipping through a ship station
you can sell anything from anywhere the
interface is on your phone
if you want to use ups fedex usps
shipstation easily compares carriers and
chooses the best solution
every time with ship small businesses
can now access the same rates usually
reserved
for fortune 500 companies just use
our offer code t-h-e-o to get a 60-day
free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress
free shipping that's shipstation.com
enter offer code theo make ship
happen
um riley mal there was a lot of uh
you know since you've been in here
there's been a lot of alleged attack on
asian
in the in the world have you heard about
this
i have and we was were you seeing any of
that
any of that on your doorstep were you
seeing
you know any anything like that were
people throwing torches through your
windows or anything what's going on
give me your feed on it man
i didn't even know it was a thing um
until someone brought it up to me and i
was like oh
that's a thing do you
see any reason why it's happening um
do you
i see i can't decide here's the thing
every day probably
700 people get attacked i would say in
america
just generally based on the numbers of
people
and the possibility of other people that
want to attack someone
would you agree maybe that yeah
so some of those people are going to be
asian
just because there is asian people
that are alive right statistically
they're just
so i can't tell if it's
really a thing or if
there's just of this 700 attacks
four of them are asian and so they make
it they just focus on them now you know
do you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
what do you think about it no i mean
you're you're absolutely right
um i mean there's just you know people
are asian
yup they're they're alive it's gonna
happen
do you have any more inside are you
hearing anything from your grandparents
are you
is anybody sending you a scroll or
sending you something you know
is there any you know any
are you getting any old school
information is there
what's what's what's coming down the
asian pipeline that you're hearing are
you guys
you know getting armored up what's is
there any intel you can give us
yeah man no i mean as far as i am in my
family we're
we're clean i haven't heard anything
okay and have anybody been attacked
you're folks or anything
no okay so it's not at your doorstep huh
not that i know of yeah
well good man i'm glad you're staying
safe and uh
and you're staying busy out there and
i'm happy to see you today bub
great to be here great to see you too
all righty let's get into a little more
let's get into a little more
um i've also got some tickets out there
for huntsville alabama people can go
check it out
uh yeah what else happened in the fight
let me think what else happened there
was a lot of i ran into a lot of great
people it was so many like
um tpw fans king and the sting
listener tpw listeners king and the
sting listeners and that was great
just running across people uh
you know the uber situation in vegas was
insane the taxi lines it was all insane
there was a bruno mark concert going on
you listen to bruno mar raleigh
i do
all right we got a we had a bruno mar
going on you had garth brooks
who was basically the white bruno mars
the white senior citizen bruno mars at
this point
and he hid the bodies or whatever but
you got garth brooks then you had
um the ufc
and uh and man it was just
there was it was just so many people
going around
and um what else yeah was that the fight
so anyway i'm sitting next to an empty
seat the whole time because i had an
extra ticket
couldn't find anybody to go and you
don't want to get a last-minute
hooker i don't feel like
you don't it's just
it's just a lot it's just because
there's that risque moment
and anybody that's ever been involved in
hookering
you know whether you've been a consumer
or whether you've sold
so weenie or sold a
female crotch that
you know i mean it's
the picture people put out there on the
interwebs is not the picture that shows
up at the door
okay it is a little different
it's kind of like pizza it's like kind
of like dominoes or you know
the thing the stuff you see on the on
the documents on the uh
pamphlets or whatever that's not it
looks good
the cinnabons are with a crunchy you
know the cinnamon
you know little f you know
chum nuggets or whatever they're called
i don't know what they're called you
know what those are called raleigh mao
i don't awesome and
so the uh whatever anyway the treats on
the thing
on the uh pamphlets look good they look
good
the [ __ ] you shows up at your door looks
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know
that's what that and and so i just
didn't want some
you know what you know some lady's got 2
000 lip injections and she's you know if
she
you know her lips are like a flotation
device in case something happens
you know like on an airplane they would
be doing the thing in the beginning like
you know a mask will fall from the
ceiling please put the thing you know
there's a life dress uh dressing under
your seat
please pull it out and put it around
your neck and she would just point her
lips like hey if we
go in the water i'm good you know
i got these [ __ ] tongue pontoons up
here
on the outside of my mouth hole that's
going to keep us all safe
you know so i just didn't want to get um
i i don't know i i did that was just a
risky move and then also i didn't want
to sell the ticket
because i didn't want joe rogan here and
oh i sold his [ __ ] ticket
even though he probably would have
appreciated it you know i know he's a
capitalist guy just like all the the
rest of us are in
in this country or you know but i just
didn't know so anyway
i had an extra seat and i was by myself
um i was right behind
uh dustin dustin's wife and
um and his like kind of family friends
tim and and um
and his wife and so it was kind of a i
could go up and talk with them and that
was exciting um
and you could see the different
celebrities coming in and now that was
pretty cool
oh one thing that's tough about
um the last time i when i got to sit in
the seats that are right behind joe
rogan
so one thing i realized when i'm over
there when i sat over there you can hear
the commentators commentating the fights
you can hear what's going on the seats
that i had this time i wasn't close
enough to hear them so you don't hear
any commentating
like at home you hear the commentating
on a television
but i i i wasn't hearing any of that
so you're just kind of looking a lot
it's a lot of
looking and listening
but not hearing like a ton
it's kind of like bird watching
a little a little bit like bird watching
um after the fight i snuck
in uh into the back area i got to hang
out with met some of the cleveland
browns
that was really cool man actually super
nice guys
baker mayfield uh austin hooper
respect man um
you know we talked about the dark arts i
guess he's
you know he definitely is uh he knew
about him
and so we discussed some of that and
and uh and
odell beckham jr met that man
um who else was back there
uh uh
david cho who's friends with bobby lee
you know that guy is uh riley mao
i do there you go
and um yeah there was some different sia
there was some different musicians
you know all the celebrities that you
saw on television if you watched the
fight
um jb was there justin bieber i didn't
get to see him
donald trump i didn't get to see him i
saw him come in but i didn't get to say
hey or anything
um but it was definitely you know
it's just all of what's going on you got
the fighters you got the
fan it was just it was exciting uh
but the difference is
the value in seeing it on television is
you can hear the commentators
you can hear what's going on and
the tough thing about being at the venue
is you don't get any of that
so you just guessing are they in an arm
roll are they in a you know
did he put him in a leg monster what
happened
you know is he bleeding is he bruised is
he
you know did he have too much you know
breakfast you don't
you don't have any other information is
he on the front foot
side control you know mission control
missionary
you don't know any if you on television
you get
joe and john and uh daniel carmia
telling you the different things but
when you're just standing there looking
you don't know if the guy
is uh you know if he's flat-footed if
he's got two
arms if he's duck you know doing a
double entendre you don't know if he's
you know you don't know if some guy's
getting beaten
uh you don't know if the if this sudden
you know
you don't know if somebody has asthma if
they won their last fight
you don't know if uh you know sugar
shawn's about to knock the color
you know the food coloring out that one
dude i mean you just
you don't know any of the information so
but it was magical uh you know it's
really magical it's just great to be
there to be able to support dustin
then i got to go over to dustin and his
wife's home
after um
and meet some of his coaches and that
was really cool because i got to ask
them some questions
uh i met the owner of the atlanta hawks
the basketball team
i'm kind of just bragging here but it
was just interesting
just just interesting people to talk to
about stuff
i they had an uber driver that drove a
brown car
and i'd never seen a brown car since my
dad had won
you know my dad had a delta cutlass 88.
he had that delta cutlass 88 and it had
he bought it off a couple brothers down
the block
and it had 22s in the trunk
and he didn't need the 22 but he
couldn't hear anymore my father couldn't
hear well you know
when i got to know my father he was in
his
you know probably about 78 time i got to
kind of start to know him
and he would drive us around and just
listen uh
you know news and public radio on
with base you know so just be like
uh jesse jackson
[Music]
you know just listening to just stuff
about politics and like
you know i mean it just
it was crazy you know listening to the
weather this is
70 percent chance of
rain just these huge
22s just rattling the trunk
and one of them had china had old
chinese food in it
and then they kind of fermented in there
but
anyway let's get into a couple of videos
that came in riley tell me about this
have you been on any other date since
i've seen you
uh i was close to one but uh no
and what kind of gal was it if you had
to describe her give me five words to
describe her
uh let's see brunette cute
funny talented
female okay
talented seemed like a re i mean
talented seems like
what was the talent uh she
you know everyone in nashville she uh
she sings guitar plays piano
musician gal yeah that's right
oh wait i forgot you also were involved
in some sort of crime thing or something
weren't you
i was and
what um yeah what did you what happened
with that did you what
what was that deal i remember somebody
sent me a picture and said
and i'm sorry i didn't check in with you
about it it was late at night when i got
it and i think i was
probably watching a movie or something
or watching a uh
one of those 20 20 episodes have you
ever seen this show i have
god it's good and but anyway
yeah what happened with you yeah i mean
just you know super long story but
basically um
you know it was just just couple
roommates um but i
am i don't talk to them anymore you know
they don't talk to me which is good
um so we've gone our separate ways um
and did you go to jail or anything i did
not okay
could you handle it in jail you think
what do you think you would do if you
went
ah i think i could handle it
i don't see that but i do like your
attitude about it man
yeah not a lot of people see it really
yeah
do you think you would have like a will
you keep a weapon on you or something
i mean in prison i don't
think that's allowed if it was allowed
oh yeah
okay right there i'm telling you look
i'm gonna tell you straight up bubbe
you don't you're you're you don't stand
a chance
you are gonna get torpedoed
in the bot if you don't have a
weapon on it's of course it's not
allowed
all right if you are going in prison by
what is allowed dude
you're done you're done bobby you know
and i'm sorry to tell you that straight
up but
you can't get to prison be like hey guys
let me see the rule book
uh you know before i settle in for the
night
you will die in your sleep by murder
not natural causes yeah you're not wrong
so i think you gotta you gotta have a
shank you gotta have a shiv
you gotta have a throwing star a death
star get a culturally appropriate weapon
get a damn uh saya or something who was
the ninja turtle that had the damn
the weird thing that nobody ever wanted
to be that guy
uh yes yes yeah
who was he do you know it um not at the
top of my head no
it's been it's been a hot minute that's
your people bubby
and he had the psy as i think they're
called or sayas or something or says
it's nice but anyway uh
yeah get a weapon man and have you
thought about the thing what would you
say if you're dying riley
uh i've not
okay do you have it has anything kind of
come to your head that was
you know your last words
hmm not that i could think of
all right we'll come back to you in a
little bit
the last words is a tough one
you know your wife shows up
puts four or five shells right in here
cleavage or whatever in your neck
what do you say what do you why did you
do it
you know you want to go out with
something heroic
you know you want to go out like with a
you know oh i'm awesome
you know like you want to get whatever
you know you wanna
what would you say
hit the hotline with that 985-664-9503
i would love to know what would you say
it's your last words you've just been
shived or
you know or poked or whatever they are
you know some asian fella hitching a
damn back with a bow staff or something
you know some freaking jeet out viet and
a damn rice rocket
just ran over you and now he's gonna run
back over you
you know he's just he's he's he's just
uh softening you up for the lord with
that honda civic
and you get one chance to say something
what do you say
ah you know go to hell i mean what do
you say
i could have i'm hungry
what do you say you got last words
what do you say it's a good question uh
we had a lot of neat stuff that came in
for the episode i want to take a peek at
some of it right now
um here's a question that came in right
here here we go
gang hey this is dakota out of north
carolina
and there's a video question and thank
you dakota for sending this in
you know and i like seeing video
question i can get a visual of you
because without visual i don't know i
hear your voice i don't know who you are
are you a senior citizen are you black
are you brown are you white
are you pink are you pink do you have a
skin condition or something
which is fine if you do
you know when i was growing up we had a
fellow bust real real tender skin he
didn't get all
uh eight layers of skin
you know kind of god's shortening them
and he he the old
five layer
and his name with franklin brother would
call him five-layer franklin
and damn sometimes you would see the sun
poke out the clouds and almost just put
him on his damn knees
dear god and so people would run over
with umbrellas or something he always
had a couple brellas on them
but damn old five-layer they couldn't
even you pat him on the back and
almost [ __ ] put him on the ground you
know you could feel his spine real well
you could feel a c-spine t-spine
you could feel his lmnop spine if he was
a damn pervert
but praise god thank you for sending
this message in here dakota
from north carolina
and if you like to talk about basketball
or
or chewing tobacco then you will love
north carolina man
it's where you could put a you could hit
a three-pointer and you could put a damn
six-pointer in your lip if you get one
of them high-dose uh
dippin snuff packets onward
i was just wondering how you feel about
the trade world
you know like the trade industries
welders [ __ ] boy electricians
you know people do drywall [ __ ] like
that
you know i'm a welder i got my helmet
right here
and i was just wondering
you know how you feel about kids getting
into the trade world instead of going to
college you know
gang baby that's a good question mister
you know i have a brother-in-law a young
fellow named ricky i think
that's his name that's what he told me
his name was
and he could have lied to me but he's
he's he said it for years that's what it
was but
he um he's a welder
and he really seems to enjoy it and
and i really think it's a good trade and
you can just be guaranteed kind of
knowing what money you're gonna make
you don't have to go to college where
anything could happen in college you
could get damn
you know you get a lot of diseases hit
the dormitories
and people get something yellow fever
riley mao you ever have something hit
the dormitories or something
i have not okay did you ever stay in a
communal living type of place for
education
i did and what happened in there anybody
come ever come down with a stomach flu
or something even
at least ants did y'all get anything in
the building anything that
you know a grievance that brought you
guys together communally
um not that i could think of
all right all right good well
that's awesome but um here's what i'm
telling you uh
brother is that yeah it's good get a
trade know what you're gonna do then
you're in control of it
you go to college you take an
anthropology
you know you take four years
anthropology you [ __ ] work in
anthropology
you don't even you know you never see a
damn insect unless they got a damn
roach hiding in a quilt in the back
so i think you have to you know you know
you're in control of your destiny
and i like welding man i do like it i
used to work at a
piping i used to work at a piping
company and my job was
washing off all the clevis hangers and
the
pipe fitter stuff and just organizing it
and
i had to paint and they had this kind of
rubber stuff
the sealant you have to put on things
and
every now and then uh this song by
sugar ray
would come on the radio
and uh
and sugar ray also sounds like a
nickname of like a
a gay man
but anyway every time this this band
sugar ray would come on the radio and
they had a song called i just want to
fly
you ever heard this song riley
i have not well you got to get out more
bubby and uh
it would come on and the welders would
stop their welding
and they'd make us subservience we was a
couple of us me and this
my tall friend billy he got bit by a
shark and he died actually
not at the same time he died later from
something else
aneurysm or pills but and god bless him
man i miss him he was tall and
and he was an [ __ ] my friend billy
was a complete [ __ ] but
uh but he had
he also was nice you know he also was
funny and we had a nice time
working together and we woke up we
worked this other
little fella named soldier
soldier this black gentleman and he was
he had on about 90 do-rags and
and he didn't do [ __ ] that's the irony
he would come to work and not do [ __ ]
like how you can have on 90 do rags and
you ain't
doing [ __ ] but we had a good time man
but anyway when the song would come on i
just want to fly
or cry maybe it could have been i just
want to cry
fly i just want to fly by sugar rays
uh that welders will make us dance you
know and they threaten us with the
torches and they make us dance but uh
very lord of the flies ass kind of [ __ ]
but we made the most of it and
and i really loved it man i loved going
over there i love the sense of community
you know i love uh there was drug use if
you wanted it
and i didn't mind that um
so yeah i think getting a trade doing
some welding you get to wear neat hats
welders have neat hats
you know some cool little deals and
uh and their wives get mad at them a lot
i remember that a lot of the fellas
would talk about how their wives were
always mad at them
and we'd have good lunches get you a
little big po boy sandwich man
go over there by sweet gerald's had a
gay fellow over there
on the west bank of new orleans the
names little sandwich place over there
named sweet gerald's and god damn it was
good the roast beef was wet bro
and sweet gerald i'll say this he had a
look in his eye like he
he's sweetened the meat personally you
know what i'm saying and that was
that made you kind of cringe a little
you know when you swallowed but after
you
you know once you had a couple mouthfuls
of it you didn't you weren't complaining
anymore
but praise god brother thank you for
sending in that question
let's get to one more here oh we got
some hood fireworks in chicago over here
let's watch that go crazy
right that [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh
and you can hear children crying in the
background of that uh that is a very
fallujah vibe
you know and hood fireworks is what it
is man i mean
here's the thing everybody want to shut
the hood down but
if you don't have the hood you don't
have hood [ __ ] going on
and you don't have this one that lasts
that last shell almost hit a damn dove
it looked like
and this is some real
i mean you almost got a they should make
a team or something this group
the guy in the backyard hold that [ __ ]
gangsta
you know these men are having a good
time a couple of adult men out there
you know firing fireworks in the daytime
that was the interesting part of this
daytime still
so you kind of wondered what the end
game was there was
firing some shells this [ __ ] looked real
i wouldn't be surprised if one was in it
drove off an mrab man
this looked real uh militario
so what else we got a lady duct taped to
a plane seat
let's look at this video somebody sent
it in thank you for the submission
[Music]
[Music]
that's a lady exiting the plane and she
look over and you see the ladies sitting
there duct taped
and they duct tape her mouth but they
didn't do a good job
have you seen this video riley
i have and what do you think when you
see that kind of thing what do you feel
what do you think
um i mean
it's a thing that happens
well now that previously they had a
fella they beat him down and drug him
out of the flight
a year and a half ago or two years ago
you remember that i do
and now it's coming to this now they're
just leaving them in there i guess and
just taping them up
do you think that this is kind of
handled properly what would you do
you're at a fl you're at 2000 feet or
whatever
you know you're on an airline somebody
starts losing it what is the uh
and you're also we blow scout what scout
are you riley eagle
eagle my bad now as an eagle scout is
this an appropriate way to detain
somebody is there a special type of uh
not you would have done um
i mean i think in uh if you're 2000 feet
in the air
uh this is the only thing you can do is
duct tape them
yeah what kind of knot could have helped
is there any knot that if you
have to keep someone to a chair what not
do you go
and this may be more of a question for a
wee blow i don't know the different
gradients
oh no um honestly any knot will do
okay you have a favorite knot
uh i like the boneline knot
or the clove hitch oh okay
okay um
and and and i want to say what do you
think's leading to this kind of thing do
you
i think there's a lot of people are not
used to being around each other anymore
we've gotten a little bit more
solo it's the me generation is
and they're all me generations now we're
by ourselves we're in our own worlds
when we have to interact with others it
stresses us out
we're not used to it
and nothing is more stressful than being
on an airplane
of course where every other video you
see
somebody's fists fighting they're losing
a tooth or attacking people
so it doesn't shock me that this is the
place where the stress
hits the fan
where the [ __ ] stress hits the propeller
and they duct taped the lady to a plane
seat
what do you think is an alternative to
uh duct taping them in like this rally
um i mean if you're
2000 feet in the air i don't know if
there is another
wrong answer buddy sedating it would be
sedating
and you know this goes back to the you
know i was at a funeral recently a guy
died everybody i know
dies and uh
and i was at the funeral i saw my
principal from when i was in third grade
and he used to be able to give me
corporal punishment
that's where they can beat you with the
uh spatula or with uh not spatula but
with the big wooden plank
and this dude roughed me down a couple
times
bill brady was his name and i said he
aged well
he aged well still looks like he could
you know
he could uh he could really put it on me
you know i mean he could it's still like
like he'd make par on my ass with that
wooden plank
you know i'm talking greens and
regulation this dude would be up down
with that thing
he knew how to work the paddle and that
was when you went to the principal's
office they could beat you and that's
what i think we should have
instead of have you know you
hit them with a couple pills give them
that butt lozenge bro throw it in that
back jaw daddy you know hit him with
that uh suppository
you guys do a lot of suppositories in
your culture raleigh
i don't and have you ever seen them or
have you ever done them
uh i have not
already well a lot of them i'll tell you
what it is they take a butt a vitamin or
something put it in your butt or a peel
they put it in your butt
do you know that i do
well at least you guys are knowing it
you know
uh and they say it's because your
intestine
absorbs drugs or whatever it is pretty
quick so
but that'll do it for you right there
getting that in you uh that's what i say
you play you know what i'm saying giving
that [ __ ] hot nugget up the old
anus and next thing you know they're out
you don't duct tape
and who even taped this lady the taping
job
is minimal i feel like
you know it's basically shoulder tape
and then just the mouth like you got a
i would say the lady also has green hair
you know it's just
we're at the point where these are the
loose ends of society
these are the loose ends of society and
god bless that lady
all right here we go right here um
a guy who looks like me
hitting on girls
[Music]
oh he's staying confident the hard part
is to stay confident and look at a woman
oh
not bad there um riley what do you do
you struggle with the
with the actual moving in for the kiss
i've spoken about this
recently a lot on this show and do you
struggle with that kind of thing what do
you
what do you where do you struggle with
when it comes to those intimate moments
i mean yeah i mean last time i remember
it was my first kiss
um and uh it was it was interesting
it was a little tough and
what is the tough part like starting the
kiss maintaining it once you kind of get
the kiss
going do you remember what the tough
what was some of the real strain uh
it was just starting off um once you're
in it you're in it
and when you're in the kiss do you then
kind of do you try and
what do you do with your hands you put
your hands around the woman are you
uh were you aiming for breasts were you
trying to make further moves or were you
just
focusing on the mouth and the mouth um
activity i mean i just put my arms
around her like i was hugging her
beautiful and was that indoors or
outdoors
indoors oh god yeah
yeah take the weather out of the
equation man keep more balls in your
court you know
exactly and was that the last kiss
you've had
as of right now yes we got to get you
back
out there man we got to get you back out
there
and how do you fend off the desire to
touch yourself then that's what i
struggle with sometimes
i just don't have that desire wow
and do you think it's because you're
asian do you think it's because you
are what do you attribute that to
because a lot of asian people have that
inner power
um i don't know if it's an asian thing i
i think it's a
it's a lord thing okay
wow man yeah cause a lot of whites are
just out here just spraying out
you know yeah
so good for you bubba
all right let's get into a couple more
questions here and also want to let
people know
that the sun's out and your bum
is out but hopefully
your pubic hair is not you got pubic
hair rally mal
i do flip flop season is upon us
and you're out here with those post
pandemic toenails you gotta
tighten yourself up our friends at
manscaped have you covered they just
launched their
fourth generation performance package
and their shears 2.0 nail grooming kit
join the manscaped movement by going to
manscape.com
theo for 20 off and free shipping
that's right the performance package 4.0
includes the new lawnmower 4.0
this trimmer will change the way you
approach your grooming routine
and you know mine was i i got one it
didn't i could get the
my chargers messed up or something but i
got to get
the one time i used it man it was good
got a light on it you can see what
you're doing
um that's right if the power goes out
you can use your lawnmower 4.0 to
illuminate the way
it has an led spotlight you can see your
junk
get 20 off in free shipping by going to
manscape.com
theo support the podcast guys the
podcast will disappear
if there isn't support for it uh
manscape.com theo for 20 off and free
shipping
manscape.com slash
theo tame that summer swamp in your
pants
with manscaped.com theo
i'll let you also know about better help
man you ever been to a therapist riley
i have not well you will one day bubby
and
and when you do man there's better help
and you can do it online you can do it
on your phone you can do it on facetime
you remember one time i was trapped
somewhere i don't remember where
it could have been daytime or nighttime
i couldn't even remember i couldn't even
see that well
but i needed help and god was he was not
a va he wasn't not available but i
needed something
i wanted something different at the
moment
and that's why i needed better help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours
it's not a crisis line this is therapy
these are licensed therapists
it's committed to facilitating great
therapist
matches so they make it easy and free to
change counselors if you don't like your
counselor get a new counselor
there's one of the biggest issues with
getting help people get stuck with it
they start with a counselor and they
stay with one even though they know it's
not helping them
change it up
change it up you're there to get help
you're not there to
you know just it's not you you know
you're there to get better
make sure it's a relationship that you
can uh
communicate in positively and negatively
visit betterhelp.com theo that's better
h-e-l-p
join the over one million people who've
taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp we all need help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
um
i'll say this also we got numer new uh
new merch available theavon.com store
uh we also have the art for sale the
podcastville art if you've seen the
the beautiful um animation art that uh
papio papiotun is done go to
theovonne.pixels.com
you can get the podcastville mugs you
can get the art it's beautiful when they
deliver it
really nice stuff to have
theovonne.pixels.com
what else i'm drinking liquid death you
know that
and it's good people are always sending
me pictures on ig of them having a
an ld and when i was young ld stood for
learning disabled
and we had a lot of it around us you
know i grew up in autism area and
real hotbed for autism autism they
called it then
we didn't know it was french or whatever
now it's
they hadn't put the all on it but you
know lance had the tism or somebody had
it
richard you know one fellow named
sharpie we had a black fellow boss named
sharpie and he had a hittatism man a
strong hit
jesus i mean just damn
a genetic swamp inside that beautiful
guy he had nice [ __ ] legs too i
remember
dear god who has the nicest legs you've
ever seen riley mao
oh man a lot a lot of girls i've seen
really so would you are you a leg man
when you fantasize brother
you a leg man or what do you think about
um titty what
i mean everything oh damn oh
okay okay big dog
um let's get to a couple questions that
came in
and uh
and we'll figure some things out here
here we go
atheo this is cam from lehigh utah
hey cam from out there in utah
and utah is
it's a great place man if you want to
wrangle a little bit of white titty
onward i just wanted to call
in man this is my first time calling in
first off i just got to say man i love
you
love you a ton man i know me and a bunch
of my friends we all listen to you
you know you're something i get to look
forward to every single week
and you put a smile on my face and you
know i'm hoping you can come out here to
salt lake soon so we could see you
thank you cam praise god brother i
appreciate that
man it's nice you just share those words
man it's important okay
but anyway man i got a question for you
uh i'm so i'm 20 years old almost 21
and i'm kind of starting to get to a
point where i'm thinking about getting
myself into a relationship you know
maybe someone i can
take out to mcdonald's or somewhere nice
like that and then touch tummies with a
little bit after who knows
oh damn okay that mcflurry baby i feel
your gang
but uh i'm talking to this girl
who recently broke up with her boyfriend
they had been together for a little bit
but her boyfriend happens to be one of
my
best friends that i love like a brother
so i guess my question is is you know
what takes priority is it bro code
can i you know chase this girl even
though she's
my friend's ex or you know do i gotta
let her go and i just gotta find someone
else bro
uh yeah dang gang brother i love you man
gang brother love you too brother um you
know this is a tough one man i had a i
had a friend recently
who was hooking up with my or
who went on i i shouldn't say that who
went on a date with an ex of mine
without asking me i didn't know i found
it from her
um and it hurt my feelings man you know
i got a lot of feelings so it's easy for
them to get hurt i got
i'm the kind i have feelings left out in
the yard i got so many damn feelings i
got feelings inside outside
you know you'll sit down on my sofa and
you're like oh man i sat on one of your
feelings here
you know i just have so much feelings
but um
you know i think you got to ask him
first that's the first move
then you have to evaluate the response
you get from him
um you also don't have to do it
immediately
you know i think giving there to be some
time
uh but i would ask him
and i would just let him know you know
hey i know you
dated someone so i'm kind of interested
in her
do you think it would be strange if i
explored a possibility with her
i think that's the way to do it you got
to start with the dude now if he gets
weird it's like look man i don't really
i think that's kind of messed up i think
it's okay to also explore some of his
reasoning
like you know if he's like man i still
really like her be uncomfortable if if
if she's around us you know if we going
to taco time or whatever
she's with us and she and i was just at
taco time i still got
you know a picture of us on my phone for
me and her sitting there a month earlier
that might be weird
but now she's over here nibbling on your
[ __ ] fajita biscuit
you know that might be weird so i think
you just got to
evaluate it because he might in a month
he might feel differently
he's going to feel a lot differently at
least if you talk with him and he
doesn't find out some other way
so that's the only way to do it man now
do we all do it that way
no i mean did i end up making out with
some dude's date who brought it who
who he brought a girl to a show of mine
in dallas
four years ago yeah you know
and i still feel bad about it some
mornings
so there's ways to do it
riley what do you think
yeah no you're right
there you go guys all right let's get
another question here
what's up theo um yo my name is kyle and
i'm giving you a call from uh
from palm beach gardens florida what's
up colin
down there from palm beach gardens baby
pbje
and that's good stuff going on down
there florida
you know beautiful people a lot of uh
you know a lot of summer hebrews down
there too you see a lot of hebrews down
there summertime
winter timing you know you'll see a lot
of people a lot of uh
pedophiles out there up in north florida
it's latinos down in south florida you
got a lot of escapees and
a lot of swamp babies you'll [ __ ] see
a baby learn to
slither before it learns to crawl like
damn
people are like oh look he's crawling
it's like i don't know he's
he's moving fast and he just ate a mouse
but
onward brother you know i was senior
announcing a lot of tour dates recently
and uh you know a little disappointed as
like i was wondering you know what's
keeping you away from florida
you know um i know i've listened to some
uh
podcasts and some other guys guys they
don't really like coming to florida i
love coming to florida man i can't wait
to get down there i want to go to
orlando it'll probably be the first
place i'll go
i think i think we're putting together a
florida leg of the tour coming up
a lot of it just has to do with places
i've been to before and then getting to
go back to them
um you know it's taken a lot of like
right now i'm like 40 days off caffeine
40 days sober from any drug or alcohol
right now
so i'm trying to just get myself in a
space where i'm healthy enough to uh
to get out and do uh touring you know
and to feel okay you know
but i'm feeling really motivated and um
and i'll get down there man we're
putting this we're putting a louisiana
tour together right now for uh
right after christmas and i believe that
we'll be in florida
and possibly even canada right after the
uh first of the year
so thank you for asking man we'll get
down there hey
theo my name is luke this one hey not
you [ __ ]
sorry we named our dog theo and yeah
anyway
what's up brother luca and that's a very
interesting name and that's a name from
another country as well
thank you brother onward um i might cut
his hair into a mullet
first of all let's address that oh yeah
mullet dog up baby dogs have had the
same shitty haircuts forever
it's about time we tighten these [ __ ]
up
you know what i'm saying if they're
man's best friend they won't mind if we
[ __ ] trim their [ __ ] up
fam gang baby onward
multiple dogs a new trend apparently
what you think
but anyway the reason i'm calling in man
so i just
i just got a promotion at work and i
live over here on the east coast and
if everything keeps going in the way
that they wanted to
then that has gone so far there's talks
about them having me move
out west somewhere a couple different
states in play but
the the question i have for you is that
my fiancee
does not want to move from from where we
are now like
i'm not even talking west coast just
does not want to move do i
do i bring it up to her that that
something might be in play because it's
going to be like four or five years down
the road or
do we wait until we get to that point i
think you wait till you get a little
closer man
you don't want to be scaring nobody
early and women they'll start packing
early [ __ ] she'll have all your [ __ ]
packed
you know what i'm saying you wouldn't be
able to you know you won't be able to
get a damn
soup spoon for the next five years and
you don't even know if you're going
she's like it's in the box it's in the
box
you know you're looking for a hat or a
summer uh shirt
you know something kind of almost
strapless summer shirt or whatever
and you can you know it's all in the box
everything
so you don't want to be living out of
boxes just because you know
even if she does start preparing if she
comes around because they'll pack
everything
you know i just sleep overnight in my
friend scott's house when i was young
and his mom would make the bed we'd be
still in it
she was just a real clean freak i'd be
in the dang bed she'd make it
what are you gonna do today i don't know
try and get out this bed
you know as i'm pinned down
so and if your wife refuses to move that
ain't your wife
bro that's a lady you used to know
who's now having to support herself
that's who that is bobby
so but i think you wait and evaluate a
little bit closer man
all right let's get one more right here
here we go
what's up theo this is uh tk up here in
northeast missouri tk and i used to know
a fellow with a one legged
named tk and uh
i don't know what it stood for but who
cares also what it stands for
onward thank you for calling man
hey i got a a dilemma and i need you to
help me solve it
my uh my girlfriend
she drinks coffee all day you know she
brushes her teeth and stuff all the time
but
i just her breath don't smell right and
it drives me nuts
and i'm just you know kind of wondering
how i should go about it should i just
give her hints or you know should i tell
her that her breath
smelled like dookie or
just be upfront about it uh
i don't know man just let me know what
uh what you think i should do and
help me with my problem praise god
brother
and thank you for reaching out to me
today about this man and and this is an
issue i think in a lot of communities
you know uh
you know uh and actually i think a lot
of communities is different
a lot of asian people don't have bad
breath really
you know they cut they got that fang
shui in them baby
you know they're all shanged up in their
way bro they really
you know they're all you know they they
get they they just have they eat small
things and it's very digestible and they
can
you know they'll have a little bit of
maybe ravioli or something but they also
follow it up with like an apple cider or
something you know they're very
they drink out of small cups they really
so they're not just
flooding the system you know a lot of
black people and white people will just
flood their system with [ __ ] chicken
nuggets and
you know [ __ ] and all of this
milkshake
so you let you you notice a lot of bad
breath in your culture
uh raleigh mao um
i don't i knew it i knew that
thank you man um but i would say this if
i dated a girl with bad breath man her
her breath got bad at night and
uh and i was afraid to tell her anything
but i think if it's a girl you love and
you're with constantly i think you
slipper a couple minutes you know
and then eventually to say hey baby your
breath is not as good as it could be and
i want the most out of you
you know i want to love you and
smell you and any woman
nobody's gonna be mad if you tell me
that bad breath
but it is hard to do but look we back
you we support you and uh and i think
that you can do it
so i really believe that you can do it
brother and
and look if somebody leaves you because
they have
bad breath dude [ __ ] um
if they're like i'm leaving you then
take your little freaking booty mouth
and hit the road you out here [ __ ]
swamp chatter
so it's a win-win situation
now unless you secretly low-key like
having her have bad breath maybe that's
what's going on as well
um i
uh i gotta run
i gotta run uh riley mao thank you so
much for being here let's what would you
what would your last words be riley did
you did you
get something i'll just say you know i
mean if i can't
uh if it is my last words and i can't
you know have more words i'll just be
like i'm out y'all
peace okay
there you go even if it's a slaying
you're at a park somebody stabs you
you know i mean i can't go back in time
if they already stabbed me and i'm
already dying you know
why not go out with bing yeah
i'm out guys peace yeah
i like that kind of it just kind of
covers everything kind of
no matter where you're at it's kind of
okay it's not really like
abrasive to anyone just like i'm out
right yeah okay
all right uh
well i'm gonna keep you in my thoughts
and prayers too to find a love of your
life one day riley mal
thanks man you know i believe that she's
out there
do you oh she's out there somewhere i
just don't know where don't know when
yeah well she'll show up man
hopefully sooner than later maybe you
think you're ready for it now
oh i'm ready there you go now those
would be my last words i think oh i'm
ready
i'm ready for the lord i'm i'm ready to
hit that next level i'm ready to warp
zone
my last words i'm trying to think would
be uh
let me think somebody's stab your shoe
[ __ ]
and i'll be like gang gang
or maybe i'll be like [ __ ] better have
my money
one of those man i would hit him with
that gang gang or [ __ ] better have my
money
but the diamond poirier won man
he won and it was exciting we went to an
after party after it was fun they had
you know the bottle you know just like
people doing stuff
like a nice sign and said dustin you
know
and it's just cool to watch someone
achieve their dream
there's something special about seeing
somebody achieve a dream
i think whether it's big or small it can
be some kid getting a
hit hitting a baseball for the first
time or even hitting it off the tee
you know it could be somebody getting
their first kiss or touching their first
you know titty through electric fence
like i did
you know it could be somebody surviving
a dog biter
or making a casserole that their
grandmother used to make
you know it's just it's beautiful seeing
somebody live out a dream
big or small that's what we're here for
man
i think sometimes it's just to bear
witness
to even life which i'm sure was
the dream of some higher power
maybe i don't know
i don't know baby but i do know this man
that i'm on the come up
and you guys can catch us here we'll be
back we'll be back on another episode
soon thank you so much for being a part
of my life you can get tickets at
theovon.com
tour uh thank you so much for being a
part of my life
and uh and i mean that you know i'm
lucky to be living out
one of my dreams and uh and so much of
that is because
of you guys so i hope to meet each and
every person that listens to this
podcast in person sooner than later
and uh you guys be good to yourselves
uh riley man thank you for coming in
brother
thanks for having me theo you bet bubby
all right gang baby we out
you